so it's very quickly getting very real
in the impeachment inquiry against
Donald Trump this is starting to now get
into people are going to have to show up
people are going to have to provide
documents or maybe face the consequences
of not doing so although it's not
totally clear in this administration if
there will be ever consequences for
ignoring subpoenas and the latest person
subpoenaed is Rudy jonald Trump's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani who has
been subpoenaed by the House
Intelligence Committee to provide a
number of different documents and Rudy
of course is one of the sort of top
people who's been involved in this
campaign to pressure Ukraine into
helping Donald Trump in 2020 by
investigating which is of coast of
course code for investigate and
determined that you as a result of that
investigation need to say negative
things about Joe Biden the letter to
Rudy Giuliani identifies him as an agent
of Trump in the scheme to advance
Trump's interests through abuses of
power and they want documents from Rudy
and I don't know that they're going to
get documents from Rudy this is an
administration that has gotten away with
simply ignoring subpoenas and subpoena
power although not uncontroversial I
mean listen there are reasonable debates
you can have about edge cases or blurry
area cases with regard to subpoena power
can subpoena power be abused you know
with any mechanism there are debates to
be had but this is an administration
that has just directly and and
unabashedly floated subpoena power
ignoring all sorts of requests for
everything from Donald Trump business
records that could be tied to emoluments
Clause violations or potential
money-laundering all the way up through
and including request subpoena requests
for witnesses to show up and talk about
possible crimes that they have witnessed
so I hope that subpoenas that are a part
of an impeachment inquiry will not be
allowed to be ignored but I don't know
the answer to that because the precedent
under this administration
has been that they just ignore them and
then there are no consequences now we've
also learned in the last 24 hours
that the Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
was also listening in live on that phone
call on July 25th between Donald Trump
and the Ukrainian president we didn't
previously know that prior to you know
12 or 16 hours ago and Pompeyo himself
is becoming a bigger and bigger part of
this entire impeachment inquiry and what
we are seeing if we zoom out a little
bit is that this is growing into one of
the most sort of all-encompassing
political scandals for an administration
in a long time and I think that it
actually is informative to compare and
contrast to the impeachment of Bill
Clinton because a lot of people on the
right love to bring up Bill Clinton in
the context of Trump's wrongdoing and
impeachment and say look Clinton got
impeached let's go back to Bill
Clinton's impeachment Bill Clinton was
impeached for lying about an affair Bill
Clinton cooperated Bill Clinton did not
attempt to tamper with witnesses he
didn't attempt to obstruct the process
of investigation
he didn't ignore subpoenas his attorney
wasn't part of the scandal his Secretary
of State wasn't part of the scandal his
attorney general wasn't part of the
scandal and this is one of the major
differences here that we see with what's
happening with Donald Trump it's not
just Trump did a thing first of all the
thing Trump did is really bad it's way
worse than lying about an affair
it's pressuring pressuring is not even a
heavy enough word but it's extorting a
foreign power to smear a possible
election opponent that's number one but
Trump's lawyer former New York City
Mayor Rudy Giuliani is involved his
Attorney General William Barr is
involved his Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo is involved documents related to
the incident in this case a full
transcript of the phone call on July
25th with the Ukrainian president has
been moved from the place where it would
normally be kept to some other place in
order to obscure and obfuscate so anyone
even remotely comparing this to the
Clinton impeachment I welcome that
comparison
if you think that there's anything
similar about the two situations you
don't understand the facts or you're
deliberately ignoring them but that then
gets us to the real sort of important
pressing question which is what does
happen if Rudy Giuliani ignores the
subpoena can you imagine that I mean
just think back to the immediately post
9/11 days at one point Rudy Giuliani was
a widely respected politician in the
United States even by many Democrats now
I want to be very clear many of those
Democrats disagreed with the policies of
Rudy Giuliani in New York City for
example broken windows policing and so
on but in a very general sense to the
extent that you see bipartisan not
support but at least recognition that
someone is a good faith actor Rudy
Giuliani was one of those people for a
period of time in the United States then
he became mayor 9/11 where any question
he was asked politically was you
remember I was mayor during 9/11 right
and now he has become Trump's hatchet
man involved in who knows how many
possible crimes involved as maybe the
most irrational reflexive defender of
anything that Donald Trump does or says
always all the time and there's some sad
element to it I read some commentaries
online saying it's actually sad what's
happened to Rudy Giuliani he chose this
he chose this so I don't feel bad for
the guy but it is interesting to look at
just how far he has fallen from being a
an American political character that at
one point at least had the respect if
not support of people on the other side
of the political aisle we will see what
happens as far as the Rudy Rudy Giuliani
subpoena